when you're smiling when you smile I
said over easy now why did I do that
when people evaluate great actors what
often gets mentioned most is range how
many different characters they can play
how many different emotions they can
realistically movingly show but I think
a criterion that's just as telling as
range is depth how many different ways
an actor can portray the same emotion I
spent the last few weeks watching pretty
much every film Jack Nicholson ever made
and it's clear that the man can do it
all but it's also no mistake that
intensity is his calling card today I'd
like to explore the ways that Jack
Nicholson conveys and uses anger in his
work the angles he approaches it from
the spins and emphases he puts on it in
order to see what makes Jack Nicholson
so great anger is an emotional response
a reaction to something that reaction
manifests psychologically but also
physically that everyone's had that
sensation of being convulsed with anger
what Nicholson shows again and again in
his roles is how anger can literally
possess the body like a spirit
this is the moment when anger becomes
aggression half the time that aggression
and Nicholson's work is realized as
actual violence against someone else
whether it's psychotic violence or in
some way justified the other half of the
time this theatrical anger takes place
in Nicholson's own personal space he
flails around sometimes as a threat or a
suggestion of violence to come one of
the time it's just a release a discharge
of pent-up energy to me these moments
the weird contortions and spasms that
Nicholson makes are more poignant than
actual attacks on people there are kind
of exploration of the relationship
between body and mind and it never feels
like overacting I think that's because
these gesticulations are all unique to
the particular anger that they spring
from whether it's focused pointed anger
or generally frustrated anger or
petulant childlike angle you see that
sign sir yes you all have to leave I'm
not taking any more of your smartness
and sarcasm see this for Nicholson and
everybody else for that matter anger can
be a form of desperation a noise so loud
that you don't have to hear your own
insecurities in Mike Nichols carnal
knowledge for example Nichols plays a
playboy who objectifies women and
refuses to commit one of his lovers asks
him to get married and he explodes
Mickelson acts a kind of anger here that
it's easy to see right through the
larger and louder it is the closer he is
to recognizing a vulnerability in
himself you want an extra $50 a week
I smell like a carpet that's the
challenge for an actor playing this
emotion you're not just playing anger
you're playing what's under it most
anger isn't psychotic it's only a thin
veneer for what's brewing below and you
have to be able to turn up the volume
while preserving traces of this deeper
motivation
that's what Nicholson excels at in the
border for example Nicholson plays a
border agent who gets caught up with his
partner's human smuggling operation when
the partner starts killing his
competition Nicholson realizes that he's
gotten in too far the key emotion in
this exchange isn't anger but fear fear
at what he's gotten himself into fear
that he won't be able to get himself out
while Nicholson bursts with anger here
but it's in the silent moments where the
actual feelings lie before I ever get
involved you understand what I'm saying
you yeah this is why Nicholson's
characters seem real and their anger
even with great writing and great
direction it's only the actor who can
make a character polyphonic like more
than one thing is happening at the same
time and even when you do that the
particular expression of anger has to
rise out of the particular character's
personality for example take these two
examples of anger which are both
underlaid with a strong sense of
superiority you can't handle the truth
son we live in a world that has walls
and those walls have to be guarded by
men with guns who's gonna do it
you you lieutenant Weinberg never never
interrupt me okay
not if there's a fire not even if you
hear the sound of a thud from my home in
one week later there's a smell coming
from there that can only be a decaying
human body and you have to hold a hankie
to your face because the stench is so
thick that you think you're gonna faint
both of these men feel smarter and more
important than the person they're
lecturing to but the first is a lifelong
military man in a court of law
Nicholson barely moves his body or head
every swivel of the neck is measured and
exact he's so restrained that a simple
lean forward feels like he's lost it I
did the job damn right I did the second
man is smug and in his own space his
movements are freer looser and they even
seemed to mock Greg Kinnear
homosexuality don't mock not on this
tour not for any reason do you get me
sweetheart no two expressions of anger
are the same not in real life and not
Nicholson's work sometimes his anger is
comedic sometimes cartoonish sometimes
it's quiet sometimes it's misplaced and
sometimes it's deeply deeply wounded
Freddie
whatever you doing stop it Freddie
whatever you're doing stop it
I hope you die I hope you die
watching so much of Nicholson's acting
you start to get a sense of the larger
shape of anger as a human phenomenon its
extremes its physicality and its dangers
but also its necessity in the course of
a life none of us can avoid anger you
can't remove it from the constellation
of feelings but you can't understand it
Jack Nicholson has a wide range of
talents as wide a range as an actor as
anybody else and yet if all he ever did
was give us these 60 years of insights
into anger it would still be a career
well spent everybody thanks for watching
that was a lot of Jack Nicholson movies
to see but it was totally worth that you
learn a lot by watching a master thanks
for watching that and thank you to the
great courses plus for sponsoring this
video if you don't know what it is the
great courses plus is an on-demand video
learning service basically means it's
got over 7,000 online video lecture
series from some great Ivy League
professors and other professors about
all kinds of subjects math and history
and archaeology but one that I think
meshes with what we were just talking
about with acting is this course by
Daniel Robinson called the great ideas
in psychology sort of which go all along
the history of psychology to to overview
what's been talked about and discovered
and that's sort of my wheelhouse so I
love to learn that kind of stuff check
that out if you go to the great courses
plus comm slash nerd writer you can get
a 30-day free trial you can find that as
the first link in the description down
there
after that it's $14.99 a month I think
it's really cool if you like learning I
think you'd really love it thanks guys
for watching and I will see the rest of
you next Wednesday